all right i'm going to make it an
exciting show today at what point during
the show today robin would you like me
to announce my future plans
oh what that's right well i think i want
it right now
you want can you isolate her saying i
i've signed a deal you have i will be
here for the next five years
here gary sal overslept last night he
just got here he thinks you're making
the announcement in five minutes
you want to bring it back no now can he
hear me now
he shouldn't be able to but soon he will
so all right what if i
say i'll make the announcements let's
have a couple of people and you have
richard and sal and stuff
i'll announce that i'm quitting and
everyone will be sad and then we'll find
out what sal's plans are now that i'm
leaving okay okay
boys i'm gonna make an announcement um
this is difficult to say
oh boy why oh boy
because it's difficult to say all right
this is difficult to say so i'm going to
say it
i'm going to ask you not to react right
away yesterday my
agent's lawyer was up here and an
agreement was worked out
between myself and sirius okay
[Music]
and i had my hands were shaking i had
trepidation when i was about to sign it
because i said gee do i really want to
continue it was for five years
sal can you not sip
it's a big announcement this year we're
all sitting there on pins and needles
slurp i'm getting dry mouth i'm sorry
i'm sorry go ahead
why are you sorry for interrupting you
with my coffee all right
how come i'm making an announcement it
always all becomes about sal anyway
do you have any contingency plans if i
say something bad here
does contingency means uh continuation
like what are you going to do if i say
something bad here what did you say the
word was even well he doesn't know the
word
contingency possibly means a
continuation no
you have contingency plans meaning
alternatives to what
to working here i ain't got [ __ ] jack
all right
i'm telling you straight house makes
this great uh no
no no no i mean i'll do something all
right look i'll make it short and sweet
in light of what sal just said i
i had a contract i had a contract in my
hands
so i was faced with either go on with a
radio show or maybe make a complete
change in my life
my wife wants me at home more i talk to
the company
they they didn't want to rearrange my
schedule at all they were inflexible
and my hands started to shake and i
backed out and i called serious last
night and i said i can't sign this
and i i sadly want to say that um
i'm i'm gonna i'm going off into the
sunset and i love all of you
holy [ __ ] and i uh so next week's the
last show
yeah this is it thursday next thursday
let me say so i'm not leaving anybody
high and dry
letters of thank you i'm sorry man i
know how much you devoted
what wow i'm sorry you're crying so i
see you look on your face and
i just like you know i'm i don't know i
got
it you know i i am so happy that you've
given me you've made my dreams come true
but
it's so bittersweet because i have three
little boys
i don't know what to do so but
it's not you you've this is not this is
nothing this has nothing to do with you
you
again i mean i'm i'm grateful for
everything that you've done for us
uh you you know to work for you the
greatest
entertainer in the world i mean
and and to give me a piece of my life
that i can always be so proud of
i i can't thank you enough this is the
part i can't take pal
i mean it i shall i love you i do i know
and i love you too but
i don't know what to do i mean i i i i
this is
i have to just move on i'll make the
best of it i've always gotten ahead
i'll get ahead can i make a vow to you
you're such a fan of the show first
place and secondly you've been so loyal
to me
i i would do anything for you i really
should have
done it now i feel [ __ ] awful but you
owe me nothing you've done enough
i mean i'm it's just uh
i mean i i you know i'm walking into
nothing
i'm walking into a burnt house maybe
there's something and that has
and that's my fault financially i should
have planned i mean i was just under the
um i begged you know i'm i'm i'm talking
to sal now but i could say this to a lot
of the people here
you have no idea why didn't you plan no
explanation is needed right now i feel
like a [ __ ] but you shouldn't and i'm
sorry
for getting emotional because you've
done more than enough
i can't thank you enough for everything
that you've done and you know what there
are plenty of people that you know
that get terminated or their bosses
resign and they move on
now this is about me now i have to just
move on and i just want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart i had to do
it
i was going crazy here and you know what
and i'm i'm proud of you
i had enough man i just can't [ __ ] do
it anymore
i'm crying because uh you know you
changed my life
you know you but is it working for you
it was a dream come true
um not many people have that opportunity
to work for howard stern is a one in a
billion chance
uh and i you you did that you believed
in me and
i gave you everything i could challenge
you and i just want to say
i'm just trying to say goodbye i mean
this is like i said it's bittersweet
we have one more week together i'm gonna
make it [ __ ] spectacular
and maybe it's even a good change for me
but i hope it's good for you i hope it's
good for every one of you
well you know we he's having privileged
to work here i just don't know i mean i
get these these little boys
they're my life you know i just like oh
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] am i gonna do
you're sons i'm so sorry
sal i apologize to you i mean i'm sorry
to the audience
to the audience i'm crying like a little
[ __ ] but
sal look at me i want to tell you
something would you like no no i mean
this is not
i don't i don't want to play this off
like it's sympathy because it's
not but you know i just wasn't expecting
this
sal look at me could you look at me i
can't my my eyes are swollen
look at my [ __ ] tears look at me were
you late today
yeah what happens when you're late
you get a goofed on don't you you miss
something you dumb [ __ ]
six o'clock i announced i signed for
five more years
[Music]
oh my god you gotta be kidding me
oh my god i can't believe
you're the only one who didn't hear the
announcements
you